ich weiß das glaube ich wirklich
99% dieses Spiel nicht kennen aber gebt
dem Spiel zumindest mal eine halbe
Stunde eine Chance es ist so unfassbar
niedlich und schön selfie hier
bin ich jetzt schon kann man hier
sterben
also guck mal wir haben da vorne da
jeder das ist jetzt unser Portal unsere
Portal Pistole okay bring mal rüber hol
die mal wie springe ich denn richtig
weit mit Leertaste
[Musik]
dein Ernst
sterben
man kann nicht sterben in diesem Spiel
man kommt immer wieder neu
gehen du bist selber nicht da ich kann
dir zeigen
[Musik]
mein Schatz echt nicht so und jetzt
müssen wir da hochkommen guck mal was
ich jetzt zum Beispiel mache ist ich
erstelle mir hier ein Portal genau
oben rausgekommen
[Musik]
nein da wo wie kann man so verloren sein
halt's Maul ah guck mal man kann sich
jetzt hier ein Würfel nehmen den hast du
auch und dann kannst du eh drücken dann
hältst du den Würfel in der Hand und
dann kannst du den bei dir auf diese
rote Plattform da drauf machen
[Musik]
hier ein Portal
Sandra du könntest mal ins Wasser gehen
theoretisch und schauen ob dann Würfel
ist
also spring
wir weg
ja wo machen wir denn hin den kannst du
nehmen und kannst damit die Leute
abschießen vielleicht
[Musik]
ja sehr gut kannst du die mal töten
ich bin kein Monster
[Musik]
okay
jetzt wieder
[Musik]
ja warum bist du jetzt hier ach so war
das falsch du solltest
Portal hier wie man hier durch
genau jetzt
weiterlaufen da den Weg lang
[Musik]
und immer wenn du dieses Ding auf einen
Punkt hält passiert irgendwie was ja
genau runter ja mach den erstmal hierhin
[Musik]
oder
der Laser soll hier hin nicht der Kubus
hier drauf
machen
jetzt wieder hier drauf
und dann gleich nee drauf halten drauf
halten drauf halten
stell mal vor man hätte in echt so eine
Portal Gun wie geil das wäre ich könnte
einfach jetzt bei mir sagen guck mal ich
mache hier ein orangenes Portal und wenn
ich dann bei dir in Bielefeld bin in der
Woche mache ich bei dir ein rotes Portal
dann kann ich immer hier reingehen und
bin dann plötzlich bei dir das habe ich
nicht gecheckt also Sandy wollen die
Situation du springst jetzt hier unten
in meiner orangenes Portal rein und
kommst aus dem roten wieder raus und
dann gehst du direkt rüber da rein
das hat nicht so ganz geklappt ich
dachte ich kann nicht darüber kriegen
weil du dich erstmal hier drauf
dann hoffe ich jetzt erstmal hier rüber
[Musik]
okay tschüss
ich versuche es jetzt selber bleibt dran
stehen
okay
[Musik]
Digger ich schwör's euch nicht ich
lösche gleich den PC dicker ich bin zu
dumm hahaha
[Musik]
PC löschen
also einmal an also Sander ganz kurze ja
komm doch jetzt nicht voran so jetzt
einmal for real bitte bleibt mal kurz
drauf stehen ich muss einmal kurz denken
oh oh mein Gott ich weiß es
komm hoch komm die Treppe hoch oh das da
oben habe ich nicht gesehen ah okay
logisch
jetzt drück den Knopf
[Musik]
jetzt geh runter holt den Ball
dicker bist du dumm
den Ball
so jetzt warte mal kurz
kann man mit dem Ball hier durchlaufen
nein
hier hoch geben ein paar Sekunden später
so du wartest jetzt hier
und gibst mir den Ball hier an so hier
ja komm
so
jetzt kannst du hochkommen
danke für den gegenteiligen Beweis ja
okay das war's mit Porsche
[Musik]